the vectors a and B are drawn in the
interactive graph below cliff click to
graph the terminal point of the vector
obtained by adding a and B whose initial
point is the origin so we want to add a
and B so let's see so vector a so let's
we're gonna start we're gonna start at
the tail of vector a and so vector a
takes us right over here and then if we
were to put vector B if we put its tail
at the head of vector a and so
essentially shift vector B over like
this we see that vector B we're going to
go in the x-direction negative 3 and in
the y-direction positive 3 so over here
you would go in the x-direction negative
3 and in the y-direction you would go
positive 3 just like that so this right
over here would be the head of a plus B
notice of a vector a and then if we were
to shift vector B over right over here
vector B would be right over here and so
a plus B would start at the tail of
vector a and go to the head of our
shifted vector B you could have done it
the other way around you could have said
all the B plus a well like let me just
take this vector and shift it over here
so this vector goes forward in the
positive x-direction 1 in the positive Y
4 in the positive x 1 in the positive Y
would have gotten you to the same point
it doesn't matter whether you're adding
a plus B or B plus a